um
using your head for once you see
anywhere
hey someone's coming i'm not blind shut
your mouth
hey you lost to something sorry
dog got a map hey rick you got a map
nope
use mine for smokes and wherever you
want to be
sure as [ __ ] ain't here hear that
nothing for you here
have a nice day now what's in the
briefcase
what the this piece of junk yeah
probably nothing
cans maybe bottles who knows
give it to me now hey take it easy boss
we can work something out right come on
don't make me repeat myself
what are you waiting for give it to him
trust me
you won't get it open anyway we'll see
about that
where'd you find it i said
where the those dumpsters over there
for [ __ ] sake josh look it wasn't us
all right
gunk was already cold we swear wait
really
and here i had you peg for top tier
mercs now get out of my way
fine take it but like chill the [ __ ] out
okay
oh open sesame
well look what we have here you just had
to open your mouth
give me a [ __ ] break already
oh
would you mind if i interrupt your
journey with a question you just did
but sure ask away it's an unusual
request
so please forgive me how would you
advise someone who wishes to learn more
about human nature
to form closer bonds i suppose you're
asking for a friend huh
i guess you just gotta hang around watch
listen study him study
that is just the advice i required a
thousand thanks for your assistance
i wish you a pleasant journey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
together
[Music]
so
[Music]
looks like we got company
you have no chance
[Applause]
[Music]
the hell is this what's it look like
branches 2021 untitled number 18
oil on canvas sheesh pearls before swine
what the hell was this doing on the moon
why else
some bougie prick hung it on this wall
half the lube's floating in space
you ever been there with the chump
change i got screaming into a mic
yeah in my dreams all right
let's bail before heads start rolling as
for the painting
you'll have buyers lining up in no time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey judy what's up hey
can you come over stat something happen
yeah just come
[Music]
you